today on the matt wall show teachers
unions are demanding to be put to the
front of the vaccine line in order to
resume
classes but now that they've gotten the
vaccine they're still refusing to go
back to work we'll talk about that also
five headlines including the biden
administration announcing that the
military will pay for sex change
operations again
hooray this is supposed to be a win for
diversity but
even if that were true does diversity
actually matter at all
or especially in the military and in our
daily cancellations some on the left are
complaining that tom brady
still has a job in the nfl but colin
kaepernick doesn't
which is a little bit like complaining
that kevin durant has a job in the nba
but i don't so we'll talk about all that
and more today on the matt wall show
before we get going here today i want to
tell you about my pillow
you know it's it's having a good night's
sleep without a good pillow
is well it's not a thing it doesn't
happen you can't it's it's impossible
your the quality of your sleep is going
to depend so much on the quality of your
pillow
and that's why you need a my pillow my
pillow products don't go flat you can
wash and dry them
as many times as you want and they
maintain their shape and best of all
they're made in the usa
and i would say second best of all they
just
they're extremely comfortable pillows um
and they're they're not quite you know
if you haven't tried a my pillow you got
at least get it and try it because it's
very different sort of experience maybe
you're expecting
but then you try it out you think wow
this is actually very comfortable
if you don't have a my pillow or know
someone who doesn't now's the time to
get one because for a limited time my
pillow is offering
their premium my pillows for their
lowest price ever you can get a queen
size premium my pillow
usually 69.98 it's only going to run you
29.98 that's a 40
savings kings are only 5 bucks more
folks now is the time to buy
not only are you getting the lowest
price ever but they are the best gifts
ever 29.98 for a queen size
premium my pillow and you can buy now
and they will extend the 60-day
money-back guarantee
to march first 2021. like i said get it
and at least try it out
and i think you'll discover that you
know the last thing you want to do is
send it back
if anything you're going to go and want
to buy some more of my pillows go to
mypillow.com
click on the radio listener square there
you'll find not only
this amazing offer but also deep
discounts on all my pillar products
including the giza bed dream bed sheets
the my pillow mattress topper
and my pillow towel sets or call
800-651-1148 and use promo code
dailywire our society you know has
always hailed
teachers as heroes selfless noble
courageous
educators and caretakers of our children
the teaching profession was one of the
few we were supposed to celebrate
unquestioningly teachers were one of
only a few professional groups
we were meant to applaud simply for
existing now this attitude towards
towards really any profession at all
was and is and has always been
wrong-headed nobody
is a hero merely for working in a
certain occupation
i don't care what the occupation is
because they're getting paid
whatever the line of work is most people
get into it because it's something they
think they can do
and they want to do and they think they
can make money doing it it's not a bad
reason to take on a job by any means
it's also not heroic it's sort of a
morally neutral motivation most of the
time
doing something because you want to do
it and you think you're good at it
doesn't make you a martyr or a saint it
doesn't make you a bad person either
just makes you a person like the rest of
us so there are there are good teachers
plenty of them
even heroic teachers i've known some but
they aren't good or heroic simply for
being
teachers and that's the distinction to
keep in mind
the problem with adopting a romanticized
view of any or any any profession is
that
it makes it impossible to hold the
people in that profession accountable
or to criticize them when they deserve
it this is exactly why this romanticized
idea
was cultivated in the first place it
becomes especially problematic when
we're talking about people who work so
closely with and have such an influence
over our children
you know this should be cause for extra
scrutiny more accountability
louder criticism when warranted because
the consequence of turning a blind eye
or ignoring
the bad things when your children aren't
concerned could be catastrophic
the teachers unions have made this
situation so much worth but
worse both by framing any criticism of
teachers as an attack on the teaching
profession
haranguing the public into turning that
blind eye and ignoring the neglect or
abuse of
our children in the school system which
does happen and has always happened
and also by fiercely protecting the bad
teachers while demanding ever more
considerations and benefits and perks
for all teachers irrespective of their
job performance
the whole situation is quite a mess to
put it mildly and that mess has been
thrown into much sharper relief over the
past
nearly what a year now when schools
across the country have been shut down
it was of course known almost from the
beginning as we've talked about many
times in the show
that there was no real reason to have
schools shut down at all as children are
not likely to contract or spread the
virus
it became even clearer as time went on
that the consequences of having the
school shut down
and trying to replace them with skype
and zoom sessions
were dire we talked yesterday about the
child suicide epidemic and one of the
largest school districts in the country
prompting a renewed push
for classes to resume in person in that
district
and yet still the teachers unions and
many teachers themselves though
certainly not all
have demanded that schools stay shut
education be damned the children be
damned
goal posts keep moving and there's no
end to this process of goal post
shifting as we have learned
here's how bad it's gotten the
washington post has an editorial
um an appropriately critical even fiery
editorial
about the teachers union in fairfax
county and um
everything that teachers union is doing
to avoid going back to work let me read
a bit this is written by rory cooper
who's a parent to three students in the
district
it says quote the fairfax county school
system demanded and then received
high priority placement for teachers and
administrators to be vaccinated against
the coronavirus
those vaccines began a week ago and
according to the fairfax county public
schools superintendent scott brabrand
yes his name is bra brand anyway 5 000
teachers have received their first dose
and an additional 22 000 teachers are
registered to receive the first dose
soon
and yet having jumped to the front of
the vaccine line
bra brand the fcps school board and the
i can't even say the last name without
laughing that's you know i should be in
public school myself
um the f's and the fc fcps school board
and the teachers unit are delaying
opening schools that raises the question
of
why they have the priority placement to
be to begin with
and whether these vaccinations should be
immediately halted so that high-risk
individuals or public servants who have
been working outside of their homes for
the entirety of the year have access
okay so let's not understate what's
happened here
the teachers union engaged in a form of
extortion really holding the education
system hostage
so that they themselves could get to the
front
of the vaccine line budding in front of
the elderly people
sick people other high-risk people keep
in mind that
the average age of a teacher in the u.s
is 42
about 15 of teachers are under 30
under 30. so these by and large
are not high risk people many of them
have
little to worry about even if they get
sick if you're 27
even if you're a teacher and you get
sick you're probably going to be fine
so the statistics tell us yet they were
put to the front of the line
and after being given what they want
they still refuse to go to work
and when i say they i mean the union now
we have to keep in mind again that there
are plenty of individual teachers who
oppose this and vocally so
though not enough for being vocal to my
mind but it gets worse listen to this
at the january 21st school board meeting
fairfax education association president
kimberly adams said she received her
first vaccine dose on january 14th two
days ahead of the scheduled start
for school personnel she has said that
her union would not support a return to
full-time education even in the fall
the fall as in september 2021
nine months after she was vaccinated the
union says that all students
must also be vaccinated adams also wants
14 days of zero community spread
yes she now wants the students to be
vaccinated too
but kids again are a very very low risk
group also and this seems like a
relevant problem
a little bit of a logistical issue here
there aren't any vaccines currently
available for kids under 10
or rather under 14 actually
and her demand for two weeks of zero
spread is a demand for schools to never
resume
ever and yet these people still want to
get paid
have been getting paid you know they're
demanding front of the line for the
vaccine
full pay full benefits but without
having to do their job
for a year now and counting
this is quite simply one of the greatest
displays of cowardice and selfishness i
have ever witnessed
and if you think i'm exaggerating
remember again that children are not
learning anything
through zoom class listen to the
teachers themselves they'll tell
you so the kids their education is being
stunted and meanwhile they're
increasingly falling into depression and
suicide
the teachers unions look at this and
just shrug their shoulders
the only thing they care about the only
thing period
at all is that they personally get the
most amount of money
and the most amount of benefits for
doing the least amount of work possible
and that has always been the concern of
the teachers union always
and don't expect anybody in the current
administration to speak up forcefully
against this
the uh the chicago's teachers union is
also refusing to return to work even
though a plan was put in place to open
schools again
so the city wants to open the schools
but the teachers union's saying we're
not going to go they're stamping their
feet
and saying they're not gonna go back to
the schools because they're too afraid
president biden was asked about this
yesterday and had a chance to stand up
for
you know the kids and for the education
system but instead
here was his answer right now the
chicago teachers union has
refused they defied an order to return
to in-person classing for
in-person classrooms because of a lack
of vaccinations do you believe
sir the teachers should return to
schools now
i believe we should make
school classrooms safe and secure
for the students for the teachers
and for the the help that's in those
schools
maintaining the facilities we need new
ventilation systems in those schools
we need testing for people coming in and
out of the classes
we need testing for teachers as well as
students and we need the capacity
the capacity to know that in fact the sa
the sick of the circumstance in the
school is safe
and secure for everyone for example
there's no reason why the clear
guidance will be that every school
should be
thoroughly sanitized from the from the
laboratories
to the hallways and so this is about
making
and none of the school districts that
i'm aware of there may be some
public school districts have insisted
that all those pieces be in place
yep there's his answer what what what to
talk about cowardice
that's the theme here what an absolute
coward
he had a chance to stand up i mean
democrats are
terrified of teachers unions we know
that uh he had a chance
to stand up and say listen get back to
work the kids need you
stop whining and get back to work
instead he talks about new ventilation
new ventilation systems
in all of the schools in the whole
country
why do they all even need it
what else do you want maybe we should
demolish all the schools and just
rebuild
them from scratch just to be safe yeah
there could be some leftover um
viruses in there or or you know you
never know there could be a virus hiding
somewhere under
a floor tile so let's just let's just
demolish them all
or better yet demolish them all and not
rebuild them because you know we might
as well if they aren't being used
the upshot here is that school will not
return this year
for millions of kids and probably not in
the fall either
when all is said and done millions of
kids might end up missing
two years of their education
missing one year is now the best case
scenario
think about that now for any kid whose
parents
took over and homeschooled they won't
have missed anything in fact they're
gonna be better off
but most parents aren't doing that
um there are many parents who who can't
do it because they still have to work
uh and so those kids millions of them
are simply going without and that will
now continue indefinitely
because of the the the chronic
unadulterated
cowardice self-interest callousness and
laziness
of the teachers unions and many of its
members
it's as simple as that now let's get to
our five headlines
yeah i just this isn't one of the
headlines but i just read uh that
the the ceo of delta airlines is saying
that they're gonna ban
they're ramping up um they're banning
system and they're going to be banning a
lot more passengers and he says any
passengers who refuse to display
basic civility will be banned and you
know
it kind of sounds like okay now you're
just going to ban everybody because who
in america at this point
would fault would it actually displays
basic civility but i'm actually
i'm in favor of this now the problem is
when airlines talk about banning people
these days it's all about the masks and
i'm not in favor of that
but if you were to take this logic and
apply it you know across the board
i'm totally in favor of that i mean the
basic idea of banning people from planes
for acting like jerks fine with me and
i'll give you one example because i was
just on a plane i mentioned
yesterday we were traveling over the
weekend and i was on a plane
and um fully pla packed flight
so i guess we're forgetting about the
chronovirus thing now looks like we'll
get so we'll see
of course you have to be socially
distant to get on the plane as we know
but then you get on the plane and you're
just packed in like sardines
um and there's someone sitting next to
me in the middle seat
and so here's here's the kind of person
that you ban i think and if i'm if i'm
setting the rules
for an airline this is what i'm doing
when you're sitting in the middle seat a
lot of times there's controversy over
who gets the arm rest well i'll tell you
right now
and i'm surprised so many people don't
realize when you're in the middle seat
you get no arm rests you have no right
to any space at all
you are an imposition on the people
around you
and when you're sitting down in the
middle seat and you have to kind of do
that awkward thing where you say oh can
i sit there's anybody sitting there
and you feel like both the person the
aisle and the and the and the
window seat is looking at you and
judging you and hating you for being
there
that's right they are and they do hate
you for being there so all you're
allowed to do in the middle seat this is
all you can do
you sit still do not move
do not speak do not eat
don't put your tray table down don't get
on your laptop
don't even read because that involves
moving your elbows this is all you do
the entire time just like this
do not move i don't care if it's six
hours
anyone who doesn't follow that rule
should be banned
so that's the first thing i would do
middle c yeah
middle c you have you are basically less
of a person
you have no constitutional rights no
rights of any kind because you're
sitting in the middle seat
i'll send that memo to delta maybe they
could think about that policy
or just get rid of the middle seats
entirely i think maybe that might be the
better situation
all right so um number one the white
house announced that it will be
continuing
trump's travel restrictions now this is
interesting
we have two things we'll play for you
they announced they're going to continue
the travel restrictions
and these are as we recall travel
restrictions that biden himself called
xenophobic before we play that clip
um here here we are at the white house
press conference announcing these
continued travel restrictions that are
supposedly xenophobic let's listen
this proclamation is part of the biden
administration's whole of government
decisive and science-driven response
to the kovit 19 pandemic a particular
note
on advice of our administration's
medical and coveted team
president biden has decided to maintain
the restrictions previously in place
for the european chen gen area the
united kingdom
republican republic of ireland and
brazil
with the pandemic worsening and more
contagious variant
contagious variants spreading this isn't
the time to be lifting restrictions on
international travel
and in light of the contagious variant
uh b1351
south africa has been added to the
restricted list
additionally beginning tomorrow
international travelers to the united
states
must provide proof of a negative test
within three days of travel
to airlines prior to departure the
president is taking these steps
on the advice of his covid19 and medical
team
my god the xenophobia and racism here
it's traumatizing to me on a personal
level it really is that's difficult
to listen to at least that's what joe
biden said
he he tweeted it um a few months ago
when president trump announced
uh travel bans from china joe biden said
it was xenophobic
and that was brought up at this same
press conference the answer
um to this objection was not very
convincing but uh i don't know
you can decide for yourself here it is
when president trump was imposing travel
restrictions in march
specifically on china then candidate
biden called it xenophobic and
fear-mongering
so now president biden is putting travel
restrictions on
people coming in from other countries
what words we use
to describe that well i don't think
that's quite a fair articulation
uh the president has been clear that he
felt the muslim ban
was xenophobic he overturned the muslim
van uh
he also though has uh supported um and
he himself even before or we did i
should say even before he was
inaugurated
steps uh travel restrictions in order to
keep the american people safe
uh to ensure that uh we are getting the
pandemic
under control that's been part of his
policy but he was critical of the former
president for having a policy that was
not more comprehensive than travel
restrictions
and he conveyed at the time and more
recently
the importance of having a multi-faceted
approach mass squaring vaccine
distribution
funding in order to uh get 100 million
shots in the arms of americans in the
first hundred days not just travel
restrictions
okay what does the so-called muslim ban
have to do with anything well it has
nothing to do with it all that's just
that's just a deflection so this is this
is obviously
nonsense and this is what you find it's
very it's very easy
uh when you're the candidate to look at
really common sense
policies like we're in the middle of a
global pandemic so you start putting
travel restrictions in place
and it's easy to throw words like
bigoted and xenophobia but then you get
into office and these are the things
that you have to do
um from the daily wires president joe
biden repealed a trump-era executive
order barring people who identify as
transgenders from serving the military
in most cases as well as preventing
military funding from paying for
sex reassignment surgeries big quotes
around sex reassignment surgery of
course because there is actually no way
to reassign your sex it's uh you can you
can you can mutilate your
genitalia but in no sense whatsoever do
you have now a
a new sex anyway uh it says by the
executive order which
the white house announced on monday
morning rescinds one trump the one that
trump issued in 2017 implemented 2019.
the white house said allowing all
qualified americans to serve their
country in uniform is better for the
military and better for the country
because an inclusive force is a more
effective force
simply put it's the right thing to do
and is in our national interest
the white house also said um this
question of how to enable all
qualified americans to serve the
military is easily answered by
recognizing our
core values america is stronger at home
and around the world when it is
inclusive
and they also said that diversity so
they said diversity
and inclusivity are our core values
well first of all that's not the case at
all so we could talk about this
on a general nationwide level
but speaking specifically about the
military now
i never served so anyone who's been in
the military especially if you served in
combat
correct me if i'm wrong right
but uh so go ahead and correct me if i'm
wrong but
when you're on the battlefield
simple diversity isn't going to do you
much good
right there's probably not a time
on the battlefield when you're in a
situation you say oh thank god it's
diverse
thank god we have a diverse fighting
force right now
unless we're talking about a you know
diversity of weaponry or something like
that but we're talking about diversity
in the way that they mean it here
once again if if i'm wrong tell me it's
just hard for me to envision a scenario
where that would happen
and the reason it's hard for me to
vision a scenario is that there's really
no scenario in life when that works
in any institution there's no scenario
where any institution
is better at doing its job simply
because of
diversity or because of inclusion in and
of itself
diversity in and of itself inclusion in
and of itself these are not
virtues it depends on
who you're including why you're
including them
what you are including them into
and especially with the military where
it's supposed to be right about uniform
uniformity one fighting force
working together to accomplish a mission
it's not about the individual so
any any any focus on the individual
on individuals desires and
whatever else orientations um that's not
going to help you in the accomplishment
of your mission
and that's not even the case anywhere
else in any other institution i would i
would imagine it's especially the case
in the military
no diversity i know that it's heresy
these days to say it but
diversity is not a virtue in and of
itself
you know we have to think about what
what are we including people into and
what's the what's the purpose
of that inclusion what is our objective
and when it comes to as we talked about
i think we talked about yes
last week multiculturalism this is you
know it's basically the same thing these
are synonyms
the problem with multiculturals what's
the problem multiculturalism well with
what we have multiculturalism within
a country within a society it means that
you have no shared culture which is to
say
the country has no real culture at all
it's just a mishmash of different
cultures
all living in the same general area but
there's no shared sense of purpose no
shared sense of identity
and that of course is the plan that's
that's the point for the left that's
what they're trying to do
um number three an article in the new
york times and i'll just give you the
headline it says
two masks are the new mask
double masking is a sensible and easy
way to lower your risk when you have to
spend more time around others in a taxi
on a train or plane or at an
inauguration
and on this so now this is this is not
just the new york times
this is because there's a new push last
few days
dr fauci came out and endorsed double
masking
and said that yeah well it's better than
wearing one
speaking of being on a plane i was
actually sitting near someone who was
wearing
they're wearing at least two masks it
kind of looked like maybe there were
three
i saw somebody else in the airport they
had they had two masks and the visor on
and yeah so two masks is better than one
you know what's even better than two
masks
listen listen to this idea brilliant
strategy
three masks why not
see when there's when there's no
limiting principle when it comes to
masks then why not wear
when i wear two why not require to if
it's really gonna make people safer
it's gonna save lives maybe we should
insist on it you can't go anywhere you
can't go to the grocery store unless you
wear two masks
or three there's no limiting principle
doesn't there's there's no there's no
this doesn't end anywhere because if the
idea behind masks has always
been if the if the justification for
masks has always been
what is the justification always been
it's been that um
it's no big deal to wear it supposedly
uh
you know it's no skin off your nose and
uh it'll make you safer
so and if if that's true and if that's
enough reason to mandate it then we
might as well just mandate it forever
two masks three masks whatever's
necessary number four from the new york
post it says
humans could live on giant orbs floating
in the asteroid belt between mars and
jupiter within the next 15 years
this seems like big news to me i don't
know that's the claim
made by top scientist dr pekka
john hunan who says millions of people
could inhabit in mega city in space by
2026.
that's not 15 years more like five years
uh john hunan an astrophysicist at the
finnish meteorological institute
described his vision in a research paper
published this month he laid out the
blueprint for floating
mega satellites around the um dwarf
planet series
which lies roughly 325 million miles
from earth
um and he says that this is something we
could do the next few years
and what people do they would live in
these these floating satellites
and then they would they would mine
ceres and i guess some of the other
asteroids they would mine them for
resources and then bring it back to
their floating
cities a few problems with this one is
that i think it would take like eight or
nine years even to get out there to
begin with
which is gonna make the process of
building these floating cities kind of
hard
also who in the hell you hear about
these plans oh we'll set up
we'll set up a colony on mars i kind of
like that idea but okay we'll go
we'll be in the asteroid belt who would
volunteer for this
who had volunteered to go live forever
floating in the black abyss
with asteroids flying past you at all
times just waiting to smash into you and
kill everybody
who who would ever sign up for that
unless we set it up as a prison colony
which that idea i kind of like just take
people
the worst kinds especially as we're
getting rid of the death penalty so we
can't
just banish them out into space now that
idea like number five from the hill says
anheuser-busch
will not advertise its budweiser
products during this year's super bowl
for the first time since 1983
instead putting that money toward
promoting vaccination awareness
this according to the company which they
announced this week the company will
retain
four minutes of ad time for its other
brands which include mklobe ultra and
bud light
according to the associated press uh
that's
the it's speaking of heroes so they're
not gonna
they're not gonna advertise budweiser
but they they're still gonna advertise
their other brands
but then the money that would've went to
the budweiser ad they're gonna they're
gonna put towards vaccination awareness
a couple of things about this number one
who exactly at this point is not aware
of the vaccine what exactly does
vaccination awareness consist of i think
we all know about it by now
and also just just to be clear uh
the reason why and they're not the only
brand that's doing this or say they're
they're saying oh we're not gonna we're
not gonna advertise during the super
bowl
we've decided we don't want to do that
well the real reason they're
not doing it is because the ratings of
the super bowl are expected to be way
down
and so they've decided it's just not
worth the money which i totally
understand but stop trying to dress it
up as some
noble thing they're doing um finally
this is kind of a bonus thing i wanted
to play for you i've had it for a few
days i wanted to play you know the girl
who did that
uh that bad slam poetry at the
inauguration
um she also has no surprise here
i'm sure this is the reason she was
selected she has
she did a couple years ago a slam poetry
performance where she was celebrating
abortion
and i thought this would be a treat for
all of us just to listen to some poetry
so here we go eight reasons to stand up
today
against abortion bands in the united
states
one let's get this straight when the
penalty for rape
is less than the penalty for abortion
after the rape
you know this isn't about caring for
women girls it's about
controlling them two through forcing
them into motherhood before they're
ready these bands steadily sustain the
patriarchy
but also chain families in poverty and
maintain
economic inequality three pregnancy
is a private and personal decision
it should not require the permission of
any politician
okay three's enough she goes on she goes
on to to eight
yeah point number one by the way
what was it the penalty for
uh abortion is worse than the penalty
for rape
what these are the kinds of claims that
pro-abortion people make all the time
totally untethered from reality uh you
know
you go to prison longer for getting
abortion than you do for
for for rape what are you talking about
that's not even remotely true
there's there is no legal penalty for
abortion
in case you haven't noticed roe v wade
is still in effect i wish it weren't in
effect
but it is and i don't expect that to
change any time soon so that's that's
just
that's her first point that's point
number one and it's a total fantasy
that has no bearing whatsoever
on reality no relationship to reality
and then the rest is i how is this
poetry someone explain it to me i
already admitted last week i'm a
philistine i don't i don't know anything
about
about art i admit but i hear this
it doesn't rhyme at all there's no real
rhythm
you're just you've you've written down
your little editorial about abortion and
you're
you're speaking it moving your hands
around a lot
and that's how you're doing you're just
moving your hands and speaking
which i do that i'm a hand talker so i
guess i'm also a poet
you didn't know you didn't know that
when you listen to this show you're
you're listening to poetry
poetry in motion well as we've been
telling you you know daily wire we're on
a mission
and that mission is to fight to take
back the culture and one big part of
that
um effort it starts with entertainment
you know rather than just commenting on
culture we also want to create culture
that's why earlier this month we
released our first film run hide fight
exclusive to daily wire members you can
catch it over at dailywire.com
or our mobile app or on our streaming
apps at apple tv or roku there's a lot
of places you can get it
the main thing is though if you're not a
daily wire member yet use promo code rhf
to get 25
off that's rhf for 25 off we picked run
hide fight because
um it's uh one that the hollywood
studios turned down because it was uh
you know they it was it was distasteful
they thought and they didn't like it
and uh many of them like it even less
now that we're involved
but the great thing is that the audience
loves it that's why
it has a 93 fresh rating in rotten
tomatoes with over 2 000 audience
reviews so trust the audience on this
one
you can catch it again over at
dailywire.com or our mobile app or on
our streaming apps at apple tv or roku
if you're not a daily wire member yet
use promo code rhf to get 25
off that's rhf for 25 off
let's get now to our daily cancellation
today we're going to cancel everybody
involved in making this happen
on twitter yesterday kaepernick was
trending and twitter provided
this explanation or context they would
say for the trend
they said as tom brady makes his way to
another super bowl some football fans
are pointing out that the quarterback's
politics i.e his friendship with donald
trump
haven't derailed his career in the way
that colin kaepernick's peaceful protest
of police violence did
arguably leading to his exit from the
nfl
okay now just to give additional context
to twitter's context the people making
that claim
are not football fans a football fan
knows that comparing colin kaepernick to
tom brady
is like well it's like comparing
colin kaepernick to tom brady there's no
analogy i can draw that will be more
absurd than that
and as if to illustrate my point that
the people making this comparison
cannot really be football fans here's a
woman called samantha palino and she
says in her bio that she
dances on broadway and she also gives
her pronouns
now i don't want to stereotype but my
immediate assumption would be that
samantha the broadway dancer with
pronouns in her bio
probably isn't a football expert
i would guess and my suspicions are
potentially confirmed by this she says
quote as we approach another tom brady
super bowl
let's remember he's friends with trump
and has endorsed republicans in their
policies
while one of the greatest quarterbacks
of our generation colin kaepernick
had his career derailed for kneeling
during the anthem hashtag
hypocrisy uh samantha you're not doing
your your gender any favors
um with statements like that one of the
greatest quarterbacks of our generation
colin kaepernick this is true in the
same sense that
pete davidson is one of our greatest
thespians
and eric swalwell is our greatest
statesman
which is to say it's not true in any
sense at all
so i can't believe i have to do this but
let me let me let me just give you
some of the numbers here especially
maybe if you're not a football fan
and you hear a claim like this just i'll
give you a few numbers you can throw out
there
uh to to correct the record colin
kaepernick had a career completion
percentage of 59.8
which is not very good um with uh with
72 touchdowns against 30 in their
interception in his final three seasons
he went eight and eight then two and six
then one in ten as a starter
and was eventually benched for blaine
gabbert which is the football equivalent
of losing an arm wrestling match to your
niece
all that said you know he did have some
historic moments on the football field
like when he threw
two pick sixes in a row on the first two
drives of the game against the cardinals
in 2015.
um very few qb's have ever done that in
fact i think he might be the only one
to start a game his first two throws
were
were intercepted for touchdowns now
let's consider tom brady
tom brady has never had a losing season
in 21 years
he has six super bowl rings 10 super
bowl appearances
he owns the record for the most playoff
wins most playoff completions most
playoff
passing touchdowns like 50 other records
he left new england at the age of 43
went to a previously mediocre tampa bay
team
and immediately brought them to a super
bowl too i don't like saying it or
admitting it but he is the undisputed
greatest football player of all time
and there is no other credible candidate
for that position
period he has won as many nfc
championships as brees and rogers and
he's been in the conference for one year
and he was 43 again so this guy's the
michael jordan of football only better
because jordan played on a different
team in his 40s
and didn't have this kind of success at
all so
if you're wondering that is why tom
brady has a career and colin kaepernick
doesn't
one of them is mediocre by every
conceivable statistical measure while
the other is the greatest of all time by
every conceivable statistical measure
just so just a slight difference a
slight difference between
greatest of all time and not very good
but a world view that doesn't recognize
merit or take it into account and
fundamentally denies that marriage
merit should have any any any anything
to do with success
is bound to have some really really bad
sports takes
as this proves and as in fact espn
proves every single day
now with that said it is true that
kaepernick's politics
his protest played a factor in his not
having a job in the nfl for the past
five years
i mean absolutely but i think sometimes
conservatives make a mistake in denying
this
where they try to say oh it had nothing
to do with it no it did have something
to do with it it is true
that kaepernick was essentially
blackballed by the league
um it's also true that there are are
people in the league now
who are probably worse than him there
are quarterbacks in the league right now
that are probably
second second and third string
quarterbacks but there are second third
string quarterbacks
in the league right now who are um
not much better than him possibly worse
but he still deserved it he deserves to
be blackballed by the league he deserves
um to not have a job in the league there
are two very good reasons for that the
first is that he doesn't
seem to really want a job in the nfl all
that much
or at least he doesn't want it enough to
cool it with the fake freedom fighter
routine
the second if we could put the first to
the side for a moment the second is that
his his mouth and his antics
consistently write
checks that his skills cannot cash this
is actually a good lesson for all of us
because you can in life and especially
in your career
be as big of a jerk as your skills and
therefore your value will compensate for
now it's better not to be a jerk at all
but if you're going to be a jerk
you better calibrate your jerkiness so
that it doesn't exceed your talent
that's the equation that's the
calculation you always have to make
tom brady could basically be as awful as
he wants to be because
he's going to come in he's going to
bring your team to a super bowl
single-handedly
so he can kind of be however he wants
but even with that being the case
he's really not that much of a jerk at
all and though he's accused of being
political
he's not political at all either
it's it's revealing how being friends
with someone donald trump in this case
is construed as a political statement by
the left
but whatever brady's politics are he's
not taking the the field in a maga hat
or doing anything else on the field to
call attention to his political
viewpoint
viewpoints he goes onto the field and he
plays the game and that's it
so the calculation for brady is very
simple he's a team player
he doesn't bring any unwanted attention
to himself or um or to his team
uh he's insanely great oh and he takes
less money in his contract than he has
to so that his teams can spend money
elsewhere to bring in other good players
that makes him about the most
uncontroversial and obvious hiring
decision
imaginable he has made it so that for
his team
he represents all upside in every area
again there's a good lesson for us in
our own careers even if we're not
professional athletes
the goal is to be all upside or at least
to have enough upside to overshadow
your downside you want to be net upside
right what about kaepernick well here we
have almost
exactly the reverse situation
he's a second string caliber player at
best
doesn't have a winning pedigree turns
the ball over a lot he's not a great
passer on top of all that he brings a
circus of media attention and political
attention which he both craves and
cultivates on purpose
he's a divisive presence and
you know as an owner or a coach that if
you bring him in he's going to accuse
you of racism should you put him on the
bench or cut him due to his poor
performance
you also know that there are dozens of
guys in the league who could bring you
the same kind of production as a player
but with none of the same headache
so this is another no-brainer whereas
tom brady is net upside
cap is net downside whatever meager
upside he has as a player is vastly
outweighed by the drama he brings with
him
that's why he doesn't have a job doesn't
deserve a job
though you know if you're concerned
there's no need to worry about him
starving to death fortunately he's
getting paid
millions of dollars by nike and a bunch
of other corporations
to walk around scowling and calling
people racist hell of a job if you can
get it
and when it comes to that job scowling
and calling people racist his abilities
are
undeniable um he isn't quite the tom
brady of race hustling that title
probably still belongs to sharpton
but he's well on his way we'll give him
credit for that as a football player
though
his career is dead and richly deserves
to be
and anyone who doesn't understand that
is cancelled
and anyone who tries to make any point
about football without ever having
actually watched a game
is also very much canceled
and we'll leave it there for today
thanks for watching everybody thanks for
listening
have a great day godspeed
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling our technical
director is austin stevens
production manager pavel ledoski the
show is edited by danny d'amico
our audio is mixed by mike coromina hair
and makeup is done by nika geneva
and our production coordinator is
mckenna waters the matt wall show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 21.
president biden extends the pandemic
timeline as 15 days to slow the spread
closes in on a year disney censors peter
pan
for political incorrectness and lazy
teachers justify their refusal to work
by whining about white supremacy check
it out on the michael knowles show